but David Laws is chairman of the
Education Policy Institute think-tank
and a former chief secretary to the
treasury greens you David lor so are you
surprised how little there was here in
bit for business not really I think this
was always going to be with Theresa
Mayes very tenuous position in
Parliament a Queen's speech that
basically had to focus on brexit and
then cut back all the other things that
were going to be controversial in the
conservative manifesto because frankly
Theresa May does not have the mandate to
push those through and is still
struggling to command a majority in the
House of Commons even with the DEP so I
think it was unsurprising that we got a
really pared down speech of this type
now as we were saying a third of the
bills that have been presented here
concerned brexit do you feel it's
inevitable the government is going to
have to adopt a softer line on things
like immigration to get some of these
bills through I think there's going to
be a direct trade off in the
negotiations with our EU counterparties
over this issue of access to open
markets versus the deal that is struck
over immigration and actually what is it
what is going on over the next few years
in the negotiations with the EU well in
many ways be far more important than
what is going on on the floor of the
House of Commons although obviously the
Commons at some stage has to ratify the
position that the government takes but I
suspect the next few years the focus is
going to be less on the House of Commons
and more on that negotiating chamber in
the EU what do you think this means
though for the invest ability of Britain
the attractiveness of Britain as an
investment location I mean before we
went into politics you worked in the
city for many years you've got quite a
good handle on this sort of thing well I
was talking to some people in business
earlier today and many of the businesses
they represented are really blighted at
the moment by not knowing what
circumstances they will face in two
three four years time and appear to be
as a consequence pulling back on a lot
of investment and actually relocating
some of their activities abroad and I
think some politicians predicted
completely inaccurately that if the
country voted for brexit the econ
he was sort of fall off a cliff the next
day that really hasn't happened so far
unsurprisingly but actually it's over
the next few years as businesses take
their investment decisions that the risk
for our economy arise and there is a
real risk at the moment that people in
business don't want to invest in our
country because they have no idea or
circumstances what access to markets
they will face in a few years time the
more reassurance the government can give
them on those issues early on in the
next months rather than years the better
it will be for our investment climate
and for jobs so in other words as well
as negotiating hard the government
really needs to get a move on and get
some of these bill through quickly yes
it does and it needs to set out a vision
of brexit which is realistic and which
helps to keep open our access to trade
and avoid just being locked out of the
markets that we depend upon as a country
for our jobs and our wealth and if that
reassurance can't be given to business
then there's a real risk of a downturn
in investment and employment activity
that will make what's going on in
today's Queen speech and in Parliament
look like frankly a sideshow because it
is that negotiation over our future in
the EU that is dominating the next few
years and the focus of a lot of that
will be outside Parliament are you
really worried then that you that
there's generally going to be a fall in
employment in the near future I don't
know when it will occur but I certainly
think that there is a big risk that
investment and hiring decisions over the
next few years could be blighted by
businesses not knowing what trading
circumstances they face and in some
cases reducing their risks by
redeploying activities overseas I think
that's already happening in certain
sectors but some sectors are more prone
to it than others so the risk was never
going to be in my view the immediate
aftermath of a brexit vote it was going
to be during this period of uncertainty
and indecision when our businesses
simply don't know what economic
circumstances they face it's rather like
the blight of investment after the great
crash and the chaos in the eurozone
where firms didn't really want to make
investments
our country in the euro area because
they didn't really know whether even the
currency could survive and that sort of
endemic uncertainty as what we could now
face in the UK for a prolonged period
and it's white a reason mates government
have got to focus first and foremost on
getting a clear position on brexit and
persuading businesses in this country
that they can keep open markets globally
for British goods and services now lest
we forget the deficit barely mentioned
in the election campaign barely
mentioned in the Queen's speech today
yeah this is probably the biggest
challenge along with brexit the
government faces isn't it it is there is
still a case for getting that deficit
down it's come down very significantly
since its peak of 160 billion but we
still got tens of billions of pounds
imbalance between what we're spending
each year and the money we're collecting
in taxes we're still adding to our debt
burden and that's a real risk if there
is a downturn in the economy because we
could then find borrowing going up very
rapidly to unsustainable levels so it
makes sense for us to go on reducing
borrowing but it's clear that the
Chancellor and the government are going
to face a very tough set of
circumstances and getting burrowing down
further the appetite now in some areas
is to spend more on things like schools
and hospitals it's going to be very
difficult to get unpopular tax rises
through Parliament with no majority so
really the Chancellor has to hope that
he can avoid having to spend too much
more in some areas avoid having to give
away too much money in reductions in the
tax burden then he's got to focus on
keeping growth going so that his tax
revenues keep coming in and he can bear
down on the amount of borrowing there is
so he gets spending and tax revenues
back into balance we need to do that
before we face the next recession and
you know the economy is always like yes
yeah one last quick one who do you fancy
for the next Liberal Democrat leader oh
I'm not really commenting commenting on
that I don't think we even know who the
candidates are yet so Vince glad to see
we've got it we've got I think some
potentially very good candidates with a
lot of literacy and economic matters who
actually will be able to contribute
something
significant to the debate in Parliament
and I think that's a good thing not just
for my party but for the country dad to
have people who can contribute to that
today
all right Dave your loss thanks for your
time there